welcome to beginner breakdown
I'm Matt Barrett scholastic coordinator
I'm subbing for Mike Hummer today and
the topic of the class is opening
pitfalls or traps in the opening thought
this was a topic that we could cover on
a beginner level just going through a
few openings and seeing what works and
what doesn't
now the books that influenced me most
when I first started learning chest my
father got me a book by Rubin fine
called the ideas behind the chess
openings and I really liked that book
because it was very straightforward it
explained each opening for example he
for controlling two of the central
squares
let's see also allowing for the bishop
to come out and the Queen to come out
okay so that one made a lot of sense and
after efore find said let's go
systematically through how these
openings play out how do they impact the
center if black responds the same way
what's the most direct route and he
started with the center game d4 now not
everyone plays this and this might not
be the strongest move but the
explanation that fine gave was very
useful I thought he says this is a very
direct method of playing in the center
what's the expected response argent eat
aches d4 and now white plays queen takes
d4 and what is it about this position
that we say is maybe not so great for
white what is it that is the main
drawback for white
anyone yes good with the Queen in the
middle
she might be vulnerable to attack so
knight c6 is an expected response the
main move is Queen III you could also
play Queen a4 you might even play Queen
d3 but because you have to move the
Queen again the suggestion is maybe this
is a little too direct another book that
influenced me and it's going to be part
of the inspiration for class today is a
book by bruce pandolfini called chess
openings traps and zaps and he goes
through systematically where certain
players may have gone wrong in a
similarly direct line of openings
including the center game the scotch
game the really Lopez the traditional
classical openings of chess so the first
one I wanted to look at was a position
arising from the center game although it
may be direct it's not a forced loss
it's not a terrible position for white
it's just not the bigger advantage that
you might get from something like the
beret Lopez
so black play is a logical move Knight
f6 Bishop g5 Bishop e7 and white makes
the mistake ePHI what's wrong with 'if
I've right off the bat if you don't know
opening theory you may think because I'm
attacking the knight I'm putting
pressure on that piece that I had
attacked on my previous move with Bishop
g5 maybe this is a logical move what's
wrong with it what can black do in
response
is there a way for black to attack two
of the white pieces at once
96 good
so after 96 White has a problem anywhere
he goes Queens c3 would be a big mistake
because Bishop b4 is coming Queen III
would also be a mistake if Knight g4
comes the bishop is under duress from
both a bishop and a queen the queen is
being attacked by the knight @ g4 and
the pawn at E 5 is eventually going to
be captured so this move e5 by white is
certainly too aggressive now when I've
played the center game I've tried to
play it like a reverse Scandinavian and
played Queen a4 and I actually have okay
so this would be this this same idea
Queen a4 it looks like we've put the
Queen on a safer Square and we just
develop our pieces normally well another
trap that might come up here after night
of 693 defending the e pawn d5 and
Bishop g5 now black has a pinned night
at f6 he hasn't canceled his King and
one lesson that we might take from an
early central capture D takes e4 is that
if your king is in the middle you might
be opening yourself up for an attack
after Knight takes e4 Queenie 7 may not
have been a critical mistake but the
follow up certainly is white castles
gets his King out of the center and the
move that black can't make here is Queen
takes e4 this is just a question of
recognizing the predicament of the black
king the bishop at f8 is blocking his
escape from the center similarly I guess
the bishop at c8 is doing that there's
an open file for the d1 rook so what's
the move in this position what can you
do to capitalize
on the vulnerable black king the most
forcing move that we would look for
would be checkmate
we don't have checkmate but we do have
check who can we check with and what
does it do
so there are only two checks that I see
three checks that I see Queen takes
Queen loses because we've just had a
piece captured a knight can take Queen
takes Knight loses because we're giving
away our queen what's our third check
yes good I think you can win a queen as
well excellent
rook d8 and because the c6 Knight is
pinned and the Queen is defended by the
f6 Knight this capture King takes d8
loses took Queen takes e4 it's an
optical illusion that this night would
be able to capture right because he is
he's pent okay now the next opening I
want to look at which i think is this
what I do do I close the entire thing
that's what I did okay so the next
opening I want to look at is the Scotch
opening and this is one that I play
quite a bit and I would actually
recommend it a lot more than the center
game as Reuben fine describes the scotch
game he says this one does play d4 early
and perhaps a little bit too early it
might have been nice to already have a
pawn on c3 when we play this d4 move but
d4 puts an immediate challenge in the
center now two ways to play this opening
that are very popular include e take D
for Bishop c4 which is the Scotch gambit
and he takes d4 Knight takes d4 which is
the mainline Scotch game the Scotch
gambit can present some very interesting
opening challenges if you play against
someone who's not fully prepared they
don't know the opening theory they may
fall into a trap a game I played just a
couple of years ago a
the strong a player he played Bishop b5
and when I played c3 he played D takes
c3 and when I played B takes c3 he
played a very surprising losing move
Bishop e7 what can white do to take
advantage of this error I'm gonna call
on someone new if anyone else knows
otherwise I will call on the star pupil
yes so in some lines of the Scotch
gambit you can sacrifice the bishop now
in this case if you play Bishop takes f7
it doesn't look like any of the black
pieces are undefended and vulnerable
right we don't have anyone sitting out
hanging when the bishop is at c5 we
might have that if c3d takes Queen
Bishop takes f7 and now Queen d5 and
this is a known mistake that might
happen if you play this guy's gambit
maybe you can make it happen in one of
your games but when the bishop is on e7
he's a little safer okay so in this
position what can we do to take
advantage and certainly the f7 square
pops out to us as okay I'm doing the
wrong thing there we go I've highlighted
the square so we want to double attack
on this square so we play Queen d5 and
now in this game I think my opponent was
sort of shocked to see this he played
the best move but it doesn't really help
Knight 86 after Bishop takes h6 Black's
best move is to castle and that's not a
good sign we can just retreat our Bishop
and we're up a piece so sometimes in the
in the Scotch gambit you can get some
interesting opportunities now the trap I
want it to look at here involves the
regular Scotch game after Bishop c5
3:9 f6 developing a piece attacking the
e-pawn Bishop g5 pinning the knight
Castle Bishop c4 Queen East 7 Castle and
the probable mistake Queen takes e4 now
the king the black King is going to get
very vulnerable so what is the beginning
of our combination how do we take
advantage of this greedy pawn capture by
black okay what should we do Bishop
takes Knight opening the king and now
how do we begin to reorient pieces to
attack a little bit closer to the king
I'll give you a hint there's a very
important black piece in the middle of
the board and if we attack it it gives
us a tempo to bring in another attacker
so the move is Bishop to d3 and now when
the Queen moves white can begin to look
for opportunities to trap that Queen so
Queen h4 how can we continue to harass
the Queen we want to bring another piece
image in the attack and we don't want to
allow black a chance to trade any of our
attacking pieces away so if we look at
d4 we see we have a knight who's being
attacked by a bishop at c5 and a knight
@ c6 and that Knight has a very
appealing outpost on f5 he can't be
attacked so when the Queen moves again
can we continue to harass it
h4 and when it moves again how many how
many squares does it have available it's
got it can't go here what happens if it
goes here if it goes to e5 what would be
the the outcome here what would white
White's plan be argent
queen g4 followed by Queen g7 mate right
so the Queen is doing an important
defensive job and that means it can't
fake eight this dark square diagonal but
it's been kicked out after g3 it simply
can't go anywhere so it seems to me that
as we study traps like this it gives us
opportunities early in our games this is
the kind of thing beginning players
should be looking for if you learn these
traps and your opponents don't know them
this could be a great way to get a point
against someone who in the later middle
game or endgame
maybe knows a little bit more about
peace activity and and enforcing moves
than you do so I do recommend learning
some of these types of ideas so recently
I played a game in the scotch and I want
to show it and ask some questions about
traps and ideas along the way I played
oh I didn't play the Scotch I played the
ruler PES sorry and there are two
different ways to play the Royal Lopes
as white you can play the Bishop a4
variation or you can play Bishop takes
c6 and I did a funny thing in this
particular game I thought for a very
long time one move one and I think my my
reason for doing that was that I had
been playing a lot of different openings
recently and so I knew that the choices
that I made
we're gonna have a big impact on the
result of the game I thought if I played
a Kings gambit that my opponent might
play some things that I didn't know very
well one thing we had looked at recently
was this very silly f5 idea it seems
like you shouldn't be able to get away
with this when we've analyzed it with
the computer
the computer says if you play it
carefully enough you're probably okay as
black and it it offers an interesting
sort of strategy early on what should
white do to take advantage of this funny
move white exposed his own king and then
black followed suit by exposing his king
the common move g5 is I think well it
was common in the in the 19th century
and it really isn't played anywhere near
as frequently now what's what's more
frequent is to follow with d5 and after
after I takes d5 to play E for which
takes away an important Square from the
white knight and clogs up this efile
leaving white with a kind of a
vulnerable pawn at f4 a vulnerable pawn
at d5 and no real development to speak
of so Black gets something for his pawn
so oftentimes when a gambit is played
the opponent will be interested in
playing a counter gambit and these
things ran through my mind and I even
thought about should I try this Center
game that that liquidates things in the
middle very quickly but I ended up going
back to this really Lopez that I used to
play a lot and my favorite player played
it when when I was in high school my dad
said always play what the world
champions played and so it seemed to me
if I was putting together an opening
repertoire for myself I wanted to play
the Ray Lopez I wanted to play the
King's Indian and I wanted to play the
Sicilian night--or and so those were the
first three openings that I really
learned
I had seen a Fisher had played the
exchange variation and I had also seen
many many games with Bishop a4 and it
gets very positional and theoretical and
complicated when you play Bishop a4
there's the possibility of this open roy
lopez after Knight f6 castles Knight
takes e4 this has played very frequently
Kramnik champion this against Kasparov
right practically sent Kasparov into
retirement playing this way right
getting draw after draw with black so
this is the kind of thing that really
prepared players are studying and they
understand that after after these Queens
come off it can be hard to upturn the
black player if you're white even if
you're a champion perhaps the greatest
champion of all Gaspar oh so so knowing
that and knowing also that the
alternative would be this thing we call
the closed ray Lopes which might go
something like this
there's so many games played in this
line that it just doesn't seem to me
someone who hasn't studied it enough
even and I'm saying that after having
played it game after game after game
when I was a kid just it seems like not
the sort of thing you want to play
against opponent who you think knows the
lines very well so I played Bishop takes
c6 now in this position this is a
position that we often talk about in
beginner classes what happens if white
plays Knight takes e5 what's the big
problem for white here why can't you do
this
how come this move isn't played when the
exchange is played and some of you guys
already know this of course because we
go through this either in classes here
or this is one of the early things that
you want to learn as a tournament player
so what what do you do
Queens e4 and you attack to pieces at
once so Ben Feingold is in the audience
here waiting for his class which is
coming up next
he always recommends keep your pieces
safe right if somebody's going to give
away their pieces make sure it's your
opponent who does that so in a position
of this kind you look to see whether
there's an undefended piece and then you
ask yourself what the result would be on
the next move if you took it and it just
turns out similarly to what we might see
in a Petroff when this efile clears if
instead of d6 black plays Knight takes
e4 he's just losing right away right
because he has a knight and a king on an
open file okay and the knight is going
to be very difficult to defend if it
retreats we're winning a queen right you
guys know this trap seen this before
so sometimes the central location of the
King or the undefended pieces are what
tells us not to go into a line of that
kind so yes oh okay sure
so after takes takes takes what about
Queen g5 yeah this move this move could
be played is it better I'm not sure what
happens there are two moves that come to
mind for me and one is d4 and one is
Knight f3
I guess they both defend the night if
Knight f3 Queen takes g2 rook g1 Queen
h3 I agree that I wouldn't want this
position as white I'm not sure if it's
quite as bad as the one where you lose
the epon but it's hard for me to kind of
it's hard for me to judge because I I
just always told myself don't don't take
that Efus bond what did the rest of you
guys think would you be comfortable in
position like this as white is there any
danger
what would Black's next move be the
abyss of g4 it looks like a move if if
we play some random move and he plays
Bishop g4 what would we do to defend our
knight again yes Rho G 3 and we're
blocking the Queen and so maybe the
Queen goes back to h5 yes that Knights
pinned and this is this is going to be
very annoying I think I would rather
play it's knowing that Bishop g4 is
coming something like d3 and then if
this happens you have several ways that
you might be able to defend the knight
92 rope g3
and you can probably finish your
development certainly don't want to
avoid you you do want to avoid putting
your pieces in these precarious
situations and once you do you have to
do something we call consolidate that is
find a way to defend them and complete
your strategic goals so maybe on the
next few moves we're going to get our
Bishop out get our Queen off the back
rank castle our King right but looking
at the position black traded a center
pawn for a winged pawn that was planning
on helping defend the white King I could
see how you might not want to do it this
way as white so back to this game of
course traps like this are well known I
played castles and and I've actually
seen a recent beginner breakdown class
that that Mike did where he talked about
what happens after h3 h5 and this was a
variation that had been played in a
Fischer game and and people have really
analyzed it to death and there's some
some really bad things that can happen
to white you certainly don't want to
capture the bishop and presumably if
you've been to this class before you're
familiar with this or this was the line
that Mike looked at said what can you do
here maybe play after we're f4 and after
this move it looks like it's just lights
out so of course I know about that line
really if Bishop g4 I was considering
playing something that the computer had
told me I could get away with a d4 pawn
sacrifice after Bishop takes and takes
something like this but my opponent
played this this surprising move Queen
f6 and it violates a couple of opening
principles we probably want to use the
natural square f6 for our night and
instead he's used f6 for his queen
and I may not have judge things
correctly again I'm following this Ruben
fine like logic that eventually I need
to play d4 and and I like the idea of
opening the centre when my opponent's
pieces are on awkward' squares and he
wants to play Knight of 6 and he can't
and if he plays 97 he's blocking his f8
bishop and his king is in the middle and
mine is cancelled and so I played d4
really with no thought this was after
having thought for about 15 minutes on
these first five moves so d4 takes takes
in my opponent played Queen d6 now what
would be a more principled more logical
way to play this out here what should
black be planning what is he trying to
do what does he want to accomplish where
is he gonna put his king can he Castle
queenside not with a queen on the D file
right so what would be a way to set up
castling queenside yes
okay that seems reasonable so Bishop d7
right and then after something like 93
Castle queenside and black would be
doing very well to go back queens e6 how
many times should you move a piece in
the opening how many times how come yeah
think of the chess opening as a race we
want to get all of our pieces out and
active as quickly as we can and a move
like Queen d6 here doesn't get any of
the other pieces out in fact it's almost
an acknowledgment that Queen f6 was not
the right idea because the knight can't
come to f6 until it's gone so it moves
again and I I abide it by a principle
here thinking I'm developing a piece I
didn't play the strongest move but I
played Bishop III thinking now if my
opponent wants to play Queen takes Queen
that's fine I have two pieces out I have
a castle King I have a central pawn and
he has no developed pieces other than
his queen who he's invested a lot of
moves in so he went ahead and played
that and now played this very weakening
g6 move and I think I was fortunate
because although I wasn't prepared with
theory in this opening I was playing an
opponent who who was kind of winging it
and so this g6 move it looks it looks
initially like he has some idea of
pressuring down this diagonal so is that
something I should be concerned about or
not are there any ways for me and I
think again to my my lessons with title
players they recommend not just thinking
about my own moves but but thinking
about what moves the opponent intense
and this is where we get the idea of
prophylaxis right we want to play moves
that are going to prevent their ideas
from being successful down the road so
moving a lot of pawns forward
is going to create some weaknesses
that's probably not to be advised pawns
can't move backwards right but if you
create a barrier on that diagonal
maybe that Bishop is stunted somewhat so
let's say let's say I played a
developing move Knight d2 in my opponent
played Bishop g7 what's the best way to
stunt the effectiveness of the g7 Bishop
c3 right and this is the kind of move
that we want to get used to seeing even
early in the opening when our when our
development isn't finished the move
plays an important role let's say I
hadn't played it and instead played
something that looks like a developing
move rook e1 what might black do to take
advantage of his pressure on this
diagonal c5 and if the knight moves
Bishop takes b2 and the rook moves back
and the bishop moves back and he's just
picked up a pawn he's traded off his he
straight off his doubled pawn but I
don't really like the way my pawn
structure looks here right so thinking
prophylactically allows you to discover
a move like c3 right okay I played
Bishop before and I'm attacking a pawn
what's what's the best way for black to
defend this pawn Hey
on the one hand he's just played beat g6
which looks like a committal move it
looks like he's planning on playing
Bishop to g7 does he have any other
options what else might he try yes
Bishop d6 what do you think about the
weakness of these squares here is it
relevant if the bishops come off the
board probably not right so if I played
Bishop takes Bishop and C takes D six
and I develop pieces I don't have a
direct way of taking advantage of his g6
move so it turns out that probably he
should have played that Bishop d6 move
certainly Houdini agrees so C 397 and
Bishop takes pawn now things aren't
going well here because soon because the
b-pawn hasn't moved I'm going to have an
opportunity to place a piece on b6 and I
needn't have had that opportunity I
think it just it just came up because
you know he missed the calm the
cognitive power of the two pieces
I played 92 and I was already pretty
sure that something like Knight c4
Knight b6 was what I intended so again I
I recommend playing prophylactically
when you have an advantage but I also
recommend playing prophylactically when
you're behind and a black player here
who recognizes I've lost a pawn doesn't
need to pack it all in and say that the
game is over there were there were
things that could be done here to
salvage this game and perhaps the most
important thing would be to recognize
what is white planning certainly nice c4
Knight b6 looks like an idea I'm
probably going to put a rope on d1 and a
rook on a1 and I may be playing f2 F for
sometime soon right so here he played
rook e8 and to be honest I mean as much
as chess is knowledge and preparation
and tactics and you know who is the the
better player there's also an emotional
and sometimes when your player when your
opponent plays a move you can tell how
he feels when he plays it and I could
tell when he played this move it was a
physical thing that he didn't think that
he had a chance and certainly that meant
that my opening had been successful
whether it was due to the moves that he
had made the preparation that I had or
just dumb luck I think in this case it
was dumb luck
I played a four and this is I think
you'll see a way of trying to hold down
the queenside again thinking
prophylactically that my opponent wants
to play b5 but if he did that here and
we simply took he has an undefended rook
at a8 right so now I thought a4 was
preventing the moves that he needed to
be playing to try to give himself the
best chance just to fast forward a
little bit when your opponent is in
desperation he starts to look for moves
that he wouldn't look for if he's
abiding by the principles and I think
frustrated here he played f5 and now
everything wins and you know certainly
as I say the result in this game was not
due to some vast opening knowledge that
I had it was due to the application of
certain key principles it was due to my
recognition that my pieces weren't under
any real pressure each time I moved and
that I had opportunities to pressure his
pieces and you know I thought it started
with his somewhat counterintuitive
Bishop to f4 actually when I described
it as counterintuitive and Ben just left
he's probably bored but when I described
it as counterintuitive in my lesson with
with Ben he said why is it
counterintuitive it attacks upon so I
guess it depends on what your intuition
is generally we would say don't
move a piece twice in the opening but
when you have an opportunity to win
material or to do something that you
think is game-changing
maybe that's a reason to move a piece a
second time and here it's just I didn't
see the immediate benefit of Knight c3
yes I know it develops a piece but I
really liked the idea that my opponent
had played this g6 move and now I was
gonna make his bishop come over here and
somehow he didn't do that and so things
really went well
okay now back to the sort of general
discussion of openings I don't know that
the Scotch game is the the opening for
you but once you've chosen an opening
you do want to get familiar with the
traps that are associated with it so
some of the time that I've spent has
been going through some traps here's
another one a 45 and I f3 knight c6 d 4e
takes Knight takes Knight at G to e7
now the most common move is Bishop c5
and the second most common is Knight f6
and both of these moves seem to make a
lot of sense Bishop c5 threatens my
knight a second time and I have two
choices I can play Bishop e3 or I can
play Knight takes c6 Knight c6 is also
very logical and after Knight c3 Bishop
b4 and I take c6 Bishop takes c3 B takes
c6 and Bishop d3 now these are the moves
that are played in in the vast majority
of games so why is it that Knight G to
e7 isn't usually played it obstructs the
bishop it obstructs the Queen and it
certainly slows down the escape of the
King from the center right so nice c3 g6
we had to move a second piece to get the
bishop into play anyway so g6
doesn't necessarily stand out to us
as a major error but the dark squares
around the King just got weaker and when
pawns move it creates opportunities for
pieces to come in notice that the f6
Square now has no defenders because
there's an e7 Knight and the bishop has
not yet come in so immediately you might
think what happens if I try to get a
knight there right if the knight was
there now it would be mate as it happens
white must think that way here pin the
e7 Knight
this way the Queen won't become a
defender of f6 and after Bishop g7 95
and there's no one who can stop the
knight from going to f6 he's going there
on the next move if the opportunity
arises and this is where an
inexperienced player might see a night
on e on d4 and say gosh that's attacked
twice by a c6 Knight and the g7 Bishop
I'm gonna take it what's wrong with this
it should be fairly straightforward the
black King is exposed the f6 square is
weak and we have two minor pieces who
can deliver a surprising quick win
yes
ah Bishop f6 yeah we could play Bishop
f6 because certainly if Bishop takes and
Knight takes King f8 we've got a good
advantage is there something stronger
yes Knight take C 709 takes a 7 yes
sorry yes ok great
and now not only can black not Castle
but with his King on ei tanned the
knight still pendant he said it looks
like there's no way to unpin that night
now if only we had a third dark squared
attacker we'd be in real business but we
have a quicker checkmate well it's not
checkmate if black doesn't accept our
Queen sacrifice so what's the move yes
Queen takes d4 and if Knight takes
Knight f6 check Bishop h6 check so Wow
the black player was he was following
principles right he was trying to
develop pieces he was moving a different
piece each time but because he created a
weakness he was vulnerable to an opening
trap and so I think as you choose your
openings you're going to want to make
sure that you choose ones that fit both
your style and also your knowledge you
need to go through some of these traps
and make sure that you filled in the
holes
what possible what possible
ramifications could there be from these
moves that I'm making Knight at G to e7
is not in itself a losing move if it's
followed up after Knight c3 with d5 I
don't I don't think black is in terribly
hot water but the way he did play g6
I just doesn't doesn't fit so we study
strategy we study some games in the
database and we find opportunity right
now this was from bruce pandolfini HS
opening straps and zaps and if you get a
book like that or you get a a collection
of puzzles you can find them online
these days easily just by googling traps
in you know you're opening of preference
I guess we have a little bit more time
so I'll just show a couple more traps
that are kind of fun here's one that can
backfire for white if white isn't
careful rather than the Scotch game
let's look at the Scotch
gambit so Bishop c5 now I had mentioned
this c3 and it takes bishop f7 Queen
here in this game white played instead
castles and d6 d6 is pretty logical way
to continue so white very aggressively
plays Knight g5 how do we how do we
defend f7 and put pressure on white
Julian 95 okay Bishop b3 h6 and white
continues his aggressive play with queen
h5 this looks reasonable right because
now we have three attackers on f7 the H
pawn can't take the night because the
rook would be hanging so how to continue
as black what's a good way to get a
piece out and defend the f7 square well
the move this yes
you night of six looks then if six looks
tricky is there a reason that he
couldn't play Bishop f7 here because
King e7 and then the bishop will fall
when the Queen leaves and the night of
g5 will hang so yeah so nine f6 I think
would have been just fine
yeah the move that was played was Queen
f6 and now white makes a pretty
significant error trying to apply more
pressure f4 okay so why is this move and
Mike has talked about this - I know
moving the F pawn can be dangerous how
come very simply it it makes our King
week okay so what's the quickest way for
black to take advantage of a weakened
King yes okay do we have do we have a
move that that employs the idea
Oh for black right so white just played
f4 exposing his King along I suppose
this gives it away
the a7 g1 diagonal
okay so d3 check King h1 now what is it
that's stopping us from taking this
Knight
yes the Queen if the Queen wasn't here
this Knight wouldn't be defended can we
evict the Queen yes g6 and when the
Queen retreats take the knight and black
thought or a white thought well I can
take a knight myself and now there's a
kind of a pretty sacrifice option it's
very forced
notice that the bishop is stopping the
King from going to g1 so what shall we
do
yes rook h2 and after King takes how
quickly can we get another attacking
piece in on the King our favorite piece
is being attacked at f6 how do we get
her in line with the King yes Queen H a
check in now Arjun the follow up oh okay
you can you can pick another move I mean
this moves pretty good right because
we're about to get checkmate but what
would you like to do Queen takes e5 okay
yeah that works it just doesn't lead to
an immediate mate if if g3 for example
and Queen down here you know now we
don't have a way to to get in but if we
immediately play Queen h8 and the King
goes to g3 do you see what we would do
next right Queen h4 check and after King
f3 what's our best move it looks like we
have two different check mates
yeah mr. g4 is a nice one and queen g4
effectively the same right okay so it's
interesting because as much as you think
you'll prepare yourself by looking at a
handful of traps you also have to know
that your opponent will have some traps
in his own basket and in in this
position this this sort of thematic fork
idea doesn't work very well because the
night at c6 becomes a very strong
defender and so you might be you might
be rewarded at times for very aggressive
play especially in classical openings
but usually only against players who
don't know the theory when you learn the
theory you'll find that most of these
positions are relatively equal with best
defense
so the overly aggressive move is often
punished with some strong defensive move
and I think 95 is that in in this case